overworked
and exhausted these are just some of the
250 firefighters
who've been battling the fire on the
slopes of table mountain despite gale
force winds
it destroyed large areas of the
university of cape town including parts
of its collections
of centuries-old literature south
africa's oldest
and only working windmill most mo dating
back to the
late 1700s was also a casualty by monday
afternoon city officials declared the
fire
mostly under control the outside of the
uct
precinct next to zona bloom across to
warmer estate and friedrich
there is no spread of the fire we have
experienced firefighters on scene to
stop the fires in this trek so i'm happy
with that
the pony destroyed more than 400
hectares of land
an investigation is underway to
determine its cause
but it's been confirmed one suspect has
been arrested
accused of arson
this is warmest upper woodstock right at
the bottom of table mountain all you're
seeing is just little bits of smoke at
the moment firefighters
packing up heading back to base a far
cry from the scenes earlier on monday
residents were packing up their stuff it
was smoke
everywhere it was pretty chaotic some
people fled to safety
others chose to wait it out
president of 40 years muhammad simon
says he's seen his share
of mountain fires all fires are scaring
okay the lost fire was massive it was
more than
a fire but this one is more windy
donations from the public and big
business have been
rolling in for firefighting crews and
those displaced by the fire have been
taken in by people nearby
there is no city like the mother city
when we have a crisis in this city
no other city in south africa responds
like this no other city has this kind of
piece where you will see these kind of
donations
and volunteer activity and outpourings
of of contributions and assistance
this is a thing of the mother city and
we're very proud that people are willing
to come forward and make these kind of
contributions right now the hope is that
the wind will subside
and there won't be any further flare-ups
and the fire could be extinguished
in the coming days robert al jazeera
cape town